spill i'm joined by john wall and john
not the prettiest but a win nonetheless
for the first time this season the
rockets have won three straight
where have you seen this group progress
the most over the last two weeks
man i think just getting the trades in
getting people that want to be here
uh committing on both ends of the floor
um the third quarter was nasty
basketball
uh we couldn't make shots he was turning
the ball though he wasn't playing
defense but uh this is me a big first
game it's probably our first game with
all our guys there
except for christian woods i think we're
going to get better from here oh this is
only my second game
at the mission five so i'm just getting
my legs back i think it's gonna be a lot
of fun to be around here
you talk about how it's a total team
effort tonight from your starters and
your second unit the team is seven and
one when the bench out scores the
opponent's bench how would you describe
the importance of your second unit
oh they're big man come on man you got
demarcus cousins when he's in the second
unit sterling brown
uh jay shawn tate um dave and wobble
come with so much energy
you know you had a man got eric gordon i
mean that's one of the best scores that
i've been around
and i feel like it'd be a start on a lot
of teams but for us he makes that
sacrifice
and then you have a three-headed combo
of guards with me him and vic at any
games that can score at will and
create for each other we know this was a
special game for you after 10 years with
the wizard the story came out earlier
where you said this game was personal
and you wanted to show that you're not
done tonight
24 points and five assists how are you
able to channel those emotions into your
game tonight
oh just play basketball man i i love
this game if i didn't get paid for i
still play the same way
i should have had 30 and probably a
couple more since i missed too many easy
layups
but my journey was going man i just felt
like those guys i know i did my things
off the court that i apologize for that
i could have been better with
but uh the love that i have for that
community in dc and the fans that love
me since for 10 years
i have nothing but love for those guys
but i just feel like the organization
thought i was done
no matter how much hard work i put in
over the summer they came to watch me i
thought they thought i was done
and uh that's why i came out and did
what i did you spent probably the first
five minutes of that fourth quarter up
near the scores table how much were you
itching to get back into that game
i was on a mini restriction so i wasn't
happy with that but i know the doctors
are doing what's best for me and our
training staff
and i gotta continue to keep working
hard to add more minutes but i was just
ready to hoop man
john wall congratulations on the win